the Russian collusion angle there isn't
any collusion there isn't any evidence
and yet this investigations ongoing and
it turns out that the investigation is
attempting to criminalize a presidential
transition now what is happening here in
my humble opinion and I'm not alone in
this and I'm not saying this for the
first time I think there is and has been
ever since Trump was elected a silent
coup to get him out of office ultimately
and before that is realized they want a
totally discredit Trump they cannot
stand that an outsider has come in and
become the most powerful man in the free
world I agree that was rush powerful
statement earlier today saying that the
Moller investigation is nothing but a
silent coup to get rid of Trump here
with reaction brand-new book on
amazon.com Hannity calm bookstores
everywhere
let's rump be Trump the inside story of
the rise to his presidency out tomorrow
former Trump campaign manager Corey
Lewandowski former deputy Trump campaign
manager David bossy it really feels when
you're going to exonerate Hillary and
praise Hillary before you investigate
Hillary and then all these people
assigned to basically all these these
anti Trump people investigating with
Muller this stinks to high heaven almost
as challenging as the campaign if not
more Sean this is worse this is the
American government using taxpayer
resources to go after a duly elected
president what I'm gravely concerned
about is we're just finding out about
this FBI agent who is an anti Trump
person a pro Hillary person who never
put her under oath who never tested who
never asked her to swear to a federal
elected official she got a pass on this
that's the shameful thing here and what
they're doing is they're using the
resources of the government to go after
a president when there is nothing there
a different set of rules for Hillary
Clinton than Mike Flynn it is a
despicable thing and I hope that we get
to the bottom of it and it doesn't
happen again no it needs to be gotten to
the bottom of now absolutely all right I
knew you both during the campaign I know
you both well during the campaign it's
an amazing I think Russia also at
another point this wasn't supposed to
happen
in the media world if you watch an
election I sometimes will play that it
was like a depressed national media in
one night all of them and since then
they've been at war you guys were a part
of one of probably one of the most
historic campaigns in history you talked
about it in your book
Sean what the books about is the rise of
Donald Trump and what he saw and what he
tapped into in the mainstream media
other than you and a few people here at
Fox never gave him the credit he
deserved they said he would never run
he'd never file the paperwork's he'd
pull out of the race he won at every
single step and even on election night
they still don't respect him remember
election night they said Donald Trump
will not make a concession speech
tonight and he won and then Hillary
didn't make the concession speech I said
well she's tired
well she's tiny Wisconsin Pennsylvania
you guys are done I'm still at this
every night yeah Hillary Clinton was
saying that Donald Trump wouldn't accept
the results of the election and now a
year later she hasn't accepted the
result there's funny stuff Utah
all right the diet on the plane yeah
Kentucky Fried Chicken Big Macs fillet a
fish but I know this is a fact but all
my favorite foods it's also like all of
us right he's a blue-collar guy he's
never changed from that and the fact
that we were eating McDonald's on the
plane and Kentucky Fried Chicken and
maybe if we were really lucky a
chick-fil-a every now and then it just
didn't really lucky really lucky mr.
Chung can we change up a little bit it
was so hard
he pushed himself and the team to the to
the limit yeah yelled that he tells the
story you got screamed at because you
fell asleep on the plane Sean I felt at
one time in 18 somebody else alerts
right he is such a driver he is a 71
year old who works 19 hours a day seven
days a week and you know you don't hear
this story remember Hillary's tired you
take a week off before the debate Donald
Trump campaign sick what about day
what about Access Hollywood that was a
moment tell that story you know what in
in the book let Trump be Trump we talked
about these important moments in the
campaign that Billy Bush weekend it was
an important it was an important moment
but it showed the sand the gravel that
this president has because he said this
was locker room talk he made his
statement and he moved on and he
delivered 48 hours later a devastate
performance was saying they didn't even
think he'd show up that's never the
Hillary people were putting out will he
even show up not only did he come to the
debye say one o'clock though I say he
won the presidency that night I believe
he did I think look I agree with you you
know why because the Republican Party
was so ready to walk away from him and
he destroyed her so badly during that
debate and don't forget that was the
debate with those four women sat there
the accusers of Bill Clinton and nobody
well then Donald Trump had the tenacity
to make that happen because who doubles
down he is so good at going after what
has happened he's gotten rid of all
these regulations then you got a
healthcare yet but you know we'll see
what happens this tax bill I don't like
some aspects of it but this is going to
help the economy ending regulations
corporate tax for patreon energy
independence 3.3 percent growth Shawn
four years the eight years of Obama
we've lived under stagnation 1.2 1.6 the
new normal of our economy no growth and
now the sheer will of Donald Trump's
personality and his hope and I'm peeing
businesses and causing shaming them into
investing in the country that's right in
the power of his pen he has grown our
economy single-handedly and he with this
economic package with this tax reform
package he is going to drive our economy
into the next round our Republicans
being so weak court look you know you
know I love working for Trump because
he's so tough and he always doubles down
and what that means is he has taken
those Republicans these dragged them to
get tax reform done look we were at the
the lowest unemployment rate in 25 years
the highest home ownership the stock
market's get six billion dollars Lauria
because of Donald Trump you know the
numbers Shawn better than any party I
said him every night for a year on
purpose that's right so everybody would
get it but he also now it's changing and
don't forget Donald Trump made the issue
of illegal immigration a campaign issue
and that was something the Republicans
refused to do you guys were part of
history it's called electrum P Trump
bookstores everywhere my web site
Hannity com amazon.com this will be
number one that's my prediction